[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
being here we're so blessed you could be
here be honest you're hoping that it's
blue right
as long as our baby is healthy we're
gonna be happy
all right hey here we go
uh-huh
it's yellow your baby is a libertarian
what I'm gonna go here look at the
ultrasounds that's the head and that's
the foot and that's a baggie of magic
mushrooms and that is a pamphlet on jury
nullification is this fetus flipping off
the camera yeah it didn't like that we
were taking pictures of it without a
warrant I don't understand it's not
Republican or Democrat yeah which way is
it supposed to vote
uh it may not God God what kind of God
would do this to a loving family did we
do something wrong
is it our fault Libertarians can come
from all sorts of households left and
right so it's half Republican half
Democrat God damn political
hermaphrodite now hang on I'm
libertarian and I'm fine
right
um well that's hurtful what kind of
24-hour news is it gonna watch it's it's
Chick-fil-A okay what about Ben and
Jerry's is it gonna hate Disney because
of the gay inclusion or the corporate
profit I don't even know what sign to
put in our yard you're not actually
gonna let it be libertarian right what
do you mean the lettuce in this
political climate you might as well
throw your baby away in this political
climate throwing a baby away is illegal
to be clear it's always been illegal to
throw a baby away pretty sure California
is still an option if you're quick about
it nobody's throwing away any babies oh
so it's a protest baby probably not a
good gift right
honey are you crying you know you could
probably exchange it for Bitcoin
baby the book
although in a truly capitalist Society
you should be oh my God this again
everybody listen up yes we're having a
non-binary child and yes it's gonna be a
monster we all invariably blame the
downfall of democracy on because it
spoils the election for the good party
my party my part my part either way this
is technically our child and we are
going to love this political Quasimodo
and hope that someday an Evangelical
youth group or a sneering University
indoctrination forces it to pick a lane
but until then
we just need some time to process what's
happened to our family
and maybe start
digging a nursery bunker
all right let's give him some space
so is it a boy or it's definitely a boy
obviously
it's probably going to come out with a
beer
[Music]